welcome to this video for the final
round highlights coverage of the
candidates tournament yeah this is the
final round but in a way not the most
exciting round because we already have a
winner of the event from Milan champion
Russia island has qualified to basically
a return match against Magnus Carlsen
which is really a sensational result I
think I'm not quite sure I'm not the
type of person who checks the the
betting odds before the tournament but I
think it could have made really good
money of you would have actually
predicted Island to win the tournament
and bet bet on it and on Anna in some
some online side okay so let's still
look at the games of this final round
I'm starting with the game to pull off
and draken to Palo on last place in the
tournament mean with the minus to score
while I'm drinking is on fifty percent
so T'Pol of certainly trying to get get
a win in but let's see what happens yeah
get a rillo pass and I think it actually
is quite a remarkable that they all play
the ruie in this in this event of course
it's the main opening yeah double king
born but there's also the scotch and and
and other stuff so not even trying to do
something in other lines okay we have a
Berlin again and this time White is
allowing this Knight d4 trade with
normally is considered to be quite okay
for black and ninety-three years a rare
set up that tapar love chooses here it
set under akin some problems he took a
while to decide on a set up but I think
you found a very good solution played d5
active set up and the center not being
content with let's say d 6 or any slower
can
can kind of build up and it turned out
to be quite okay for black to pull off
now took yeah it looks a bit weird to
give up the center but what he's doing
is actually to try to attack it with
this pieces Bishop here the night may be
coming to e3 or two before attacking the
d5 pawn but on Dragon is playing in an
act of malaise g52 finally unpin the
night and then Princess pieces actively
2g for the bishop and now deform just
preventing this 93 idea to activate
White's piece the only issue is that of
course he's got a weakened kingside this
sir has led to some weaknesses most
notably on f5 and we see that in fact a
part of make some slight progress here
he opened the center and after some
moves check really got near there five
square and down by a very concrete play
now and recognizes White's activity
Queen here and it looks a bit a bit
tricky isn't white coming here here but
he has a good move replace Queenie for
this was certainly anticipated in
advance that now white is almost forced
to exchange Queens FD for is also
hanging if you go here there is Bishop
oops to d8 what the pile of tried is
something different he tried night f5
just attacking on age six and black I
really AM cannot cannot just ignore this
he gave up this pawn simply for activity
putting the rukon d8 king age seven was
not good you two looks you want with a
very very great with a very bad pin on
the night
so this is this is okay roop to the aid
keeping up the porn and activating the
king of the process so white has one
upon but okay well this is one of those
double bonds it's not like he's getting
a passport soon and it turned out that
especially the night only six was a very
good defender wider couldn't go couldn't
make any sort of progress they played
this up to 60 something know what
precisely yeah till here and there was
simply no progress to be made to pull
off tried hard but there is nothing
nothing to do really so draw for those
two under aching I guess I'm pretty
satisfied with his result but Apollo
office certainly glad that this affairs
over he's on a midas to score and on
last place alright so next game to look
is look at his mum adyar of chromic both
players on the fifty percent score not
great for Chrome Nick for Mammadyarov I
guess a so-so result I think he had had
ambitions for this tournament and you
could see that he was quite well
prepared in most openings he had ideas
and so on but he had this game against
Kramnik which she had in which he had a
winning position and lost ultimately
which is probably one of the key points
of the tournament okay we got a little
here with Quincy to a very very solid
line for black this had been played
already in the tournament the first
round game Drake in chronic when Drake
and played Quincy to chronic there also
um didn't have any big problems in
equalizing in fact they played a sort of
completely let's say
game that was completely prepared and
here Mammadyarov even goes for the Queen
trade after some thought well I'm not
quite sure about all this maybe he was
content with the draw anyway but this
cannot endanger black in any case he
played this in this fashion I think
actually now with Bishop e7 Kramnik is
making a precise move he could have
taken and after that it let's say after
after him and that's a here ya know what
has a little learn something not great
but something to play for and Bishop d7
seems to be more precise it keeps some
pressure on the long diagonal and makes
wide loose and move even with f3 or
let's say yeah play an on developing
move and this like actually could could
use to completely equalize on the
queenside we had those mess trades now
yeah we need new 32 to agree a draw and
here they agreed and a completely dead
position yeah a bit of a non game it's a
it's really not much to talk about about
here this is a very solid line and
though for both players there's no
particular reason to to do anything
drastic in this in this game I mean it's
it's a kind of a game where you just try
hope that the opponent is doing
something crazy then you maybe can do
something but it's not like they'd
certainly play the Budapest gambit to to
even do sir for change sorry for the
Budapest fans but let's say some sort of
offbeat opening as it's not really
making much sense in this context
alright a draw here so what else do we
got we got of course aronian karaoke
look at this that game both players on
fifty percent before the round aronian
always he was on a good yeah he was on
track at times he had a good score plus
1 and but he never really could get near
near on and he had some some chances
that he didn't take and now after losing
against and raking in the wrong before
he's really back on fifty percent okay
let's see what what happens here ronnian
playing efore surprisingly but he has
not prepared any sort of big theoretical
innovation he's just playing this type
of chess developing not doing any
thought of preparation on war with
kayaking just playing natural stuff and
in the long run trying to get something
in the center here with the letter C 3
and T 4 this is not the most ambitious
way ever to play but it keeps pieces on
the board and it gets to an interesting
position it's not like it's completely
boring after d5 got a 597 and c3 and
here we see the conflict in this game
white wants to do deform and get
structure typical of the French defense
which I think would be quite favorable
for white because the bishop is not so
well placed on b7 with the bishop won't
be seven in the French structure you
have some some issues often it's not
doing much really it does not protect
esox so that you can easily play f6 and
well you also cannot exchange it easily
in this structure what I think would be
somewhat better if he could get defined
so kayaking plays d for himself and we
get a very unconventional structure here
with black heading play to be three and
it's a bit about tactical nuances here
which I explained a bit in the in the
longer version of this but it came down
to this position where 94 exchanges the
c5 night that had landed protection to
the b3 porn so white is scanning this
pawn it looks all nice but starting from
here I don't really understand what
their own ian is doing I'm honest with
you I don't understand it he's now not
playing before too yeah just advancing
this this this week pawn trying to try
to keep it but he's setting up this kind
of passive defense against Blacks
pressure which does not lead to anything
and in fact here after this kayaking has
a nice chance that he takes he
sacrifices the exchange on f3 which
Aronian could have prevented with with
Bishop d3 for for example here it just
there's not much happening I think white
had some chances before for an edge but
this is just good compensation yeah
after Queen c1 ki can sacrifice the
exchange it's a full exchange black has
got no pawn for that but it's still very
good compensation the dark squares are
really weak and the night can easily
join the action on d5 you see that black
is getting a substantial initiative here
and now even gets to use the rookie on
the fifth-ranked which he I was
prevented now with h4 so that no rook is
coming to d5 now a couple of moves later
like I got the exchange back and had a
generally nice position no doubt about
that here there was a question should
you go Queen G for exchanging Queens
which leads to a somewhat uncomfortable
end game or qui g3 not going from the
end game maybe the end game was was
better this now is quite quite an
uncomfortable position I think uronian
had just based his play on calculation
you thought that no F was a threat so
ruka for is the way to go
and then Rudy for this is what he had
planned I believe and thought that this
is a tenable position that's maybe true
okay but it's just so uncomfortable
White's King is a constant very those
pawns this pawn is weak Bishop it's not
great it's just not much fun I mean it's
also very tricky to analyzed to
determine what kind of defensive set up
white should have tried at the end after
long maneuvers wrong and actually I
didn't find the best defense going up to
this point here he probably needed to
play em Queen g2 which is very ugly but
what you did is losing after Queen B to
the problem is that you cannot move the
bishop here just before that you can
take ok and you have no way really to to
do things here this got this coming here
white is already losing material he gave
up the bishop in that way and well could
have resigned with the clear conscience
but he he continued a couple of normals
probably be very much disappointed by
all of this check check do this in a
very quick fast forward manner here on
aronian resigned to really complete a
really disappointing tournament for him
being the pretty much clear favorite of
the event before then at the end ending
with the minus one score losing the last
two games yeah of course if he plays
those two games it's not much of a
difference when I was going to trying to
say if you it's not great to lose those
two of course but it was not really a
going well um before even I think a very
important point was
besides the fact that he lost the first
game against island which was quite bad
in terms of tiebreak situation and so on
but I think one key point was the game
that he lost against Mammadyarov with
black where he got in this very sharp
preparation that terribly backfired and
after that I think he was almost out of
it not really I didn't don't think he
really had a big chance anymore after
the loss in this game okay so the final
game to cover is the game of the winner
vishy anand against Peter Svidler and
yeah well as some as Island said after
the game he wanted to play a player safe
game okay let's see how this looks like
also because it turned out that yet they
had quite some some celebration um after
he qualified of course if i'm not
mistaken on erdus not drinking any
alcohol so it wasn't a kind of hangover
situation yeah in the board but it's
just clear that you wanted to save a
safe game and this is by allowing the
marshal you usually get that on this
level because white has many lines
available against the marshal attack
that are very safe and d3 Queen f3 is
such a line that it seems I had a look
at the brief theoretical outlines of
this I'm not an expert at all of the
marshal attack but it seems that this is
a very safe line Queen f6 and this is
all latest fashion here black cam has
actually a big threat Bishop g4 this you
should look at like this and the queen
is strapped surprisingly this is why
Bishop d1 was played it looks a bit odd
this Bishop move but okay you needed to
cover this idea and it basically forces
black to take on d3 giving the porn back
after 94 now we see why it's point this
is a hanging bishop you cannot really
anywhere besides taking it and now we
right out of the opening have transposed
into an end game situation with two
rooks both sides and white having the
bishop and looks nice but black has the
the momentum is got the tambien
threatening and made now white needs to
cover that and now Sevilla gets in his
improvement Bishop f4 improvement means
this has been played before in a game
last year between grandmother's Caruana
and Kasim Jean off their Bishop g5 the
square Bishop f4 seems to be an even
clearer up equalizer we get some more
trades and and now a 3 a 3 actually is
the new move compared to a game that
Alex oshiro has played just a couple of
weeks ago it all seems to be a rather
yeah it's very Jewish let's put it that
way night f4 is the active defense black
also could have tried 97 trying to hang
on in a bit of a passive fashion but
neither force probably the cleanest
solution actively going forward to
attack me too and with precise play we
got many more trades check and at the
end are totally clearance on the on the
queenside um so we draw a tree TM a very
much expected turn of events in this
game and not really in a fighting mood
anymore understandably after he has has
won the tournament already what's villa
is certainly a doctor let's say trying
to play some sort of dubious gambit here
tried to confuse Russia for whatever
reason a draw is perfectly okay with a
long tournament and why not why not
agree to this draw here in former times
when they didn't have those draw rules
not allowing a grete draw before more 30
they may be a good if agreed
even alright so this tournament is over
the coverage for this tournament is also
completed I have analyzed all the games
and single videos so if you do a quick
calculation 14 rounds for games which
means a hell of a lot of chess is this
2840 wow this is like 65 games and some
of the videos are quite long for those
of you are also who really watched all
of it you're tough ok I hope you enjoyed
the coverage I think it was a very
interesting tournament with an
unexpected result really we had lots of
interesting games especially in the
first half of the tournament um I think
this is also due to the fact that 14
rounds is quite quite a long distance
many games and you shouldn't forget that
it's not just the games that that needs
to be played but also the the
preparation and all the tension of like
three hours of top-level chest it really
am three hours three weeks gets to you
so I think the quality of the games
deteriorated a bit at the end but there
are many many interesting games plane
and only very little games that didn't
have much content and mostly near the
end of the event yeah I hope you enjoyed
the coverage thanks for watching I think
by the way I'll be back with covering
top-level chess quite soon but not to
this extent enough like doing all the
games there is some remarkable
tournament coming up the the gushy more
for memorial tournament and this will
also feature the world champion magnus
carlsen I'll do some coverage of that's
this tournament certainly with a daily
video maybe two and need to see what
time I
and I can can spend on this alright
thanks for watching